YOU PAY FOR YOUR LACK OF
COMMUNICATION.
>> Brian: TRAE YOUNG.
MILTON WITH A REBOUND.
15-POINT PHILADELPHIA LEAD.
17 OF THE 36 COMING FROM EMBIID.
TURNER CLOSE BY.
DOUBLE.
THYBULLE.
HE'LL GO TO THE HOLE.
LEAVE IT.
THAT'S SIMMONS!
BEAUTIFUL OFFENSE, AS THYBULLE
SET UP BEN SIMMONS!
AND NOW EMBIID JAWING WITH
CAPELA.
OFFICIALS GET BETWEEN THEM.
SIXERS WITH ALL KIND OF SWAGGER
HERE TONIGHT IN FRONT OF THEIR
HOME CROWD
.
IT WILL BE A TECHNICAL,I
BELIEVE ON EMBIID.
YOUNG WILL KNOCK IT DOWN.
SAW SIMMONS AND GALLINARI, THEN
EMBIID JAWING AT CAPELA.
AND DAVID GUTHRIE HITS HIM WITH
A "T."
>> Jim: MUST HAVE SAID SOME
MAGICAL WORDS.
IN THE PLAYOFFS YOU KNOW THE
EMOTIONS ARE GOING TO BE HIGH.
REFEREES WOULD ALLOW SOME OF
THAT, BUT MUST HAVE SAID